i
[Música]
ah
la pandemia de coronavirus ha recordado
a todas las personas la importancia de
la salud pero no solo la de evitar
contagiarse de coronavirus sino también
la salud mental el aislamiento y el
sentimiento de soledad que puede
provocar el confinamiento ha hecho que
bélgica permita a todas las personas
tener lo que se conoce como un contacto
estrecho el neerlandés se conoce como el
contact y que se podría traducir algo
así como compañero de mimos todas las
familias convivientes pueden escoger a
una persona a la que pueden abrazar
también invitar a sus casas pero esta
persona no puede escoger a nadie más por
otra parte las personas que vivan solas
si pueden escoger a dos personas las que
pueden abrazar o invitar a su casa pero
nunca a la vez bélgica que ha vivido con
muchísima más intensidad de esta segunda
ola de coronavirus también quiere
priorizar la salud mental de su
población especialmente en momentos tan
duros como los actuales
[Música]
en eeuu y antes de la crisis del
coronavirus las autoridades sanitarias
ya advertían de otra pandemia la de la
soledad a los expertos alertan que
sentirse solo es tan dañino como fumar
15 cigarrillos una situación acentuada
mucho más hoy en día a raíz de lakovic
19 de hecho un estudio de la escuela
bloomberg de salud pública y de la
universidad johns hopkins reveló que
actualmente el nivel de ansiedad y
soledad en eeuu había incrementado en
por lo menos un 3% durante la pandemia
en comparación con datos de 2018 lakovic
19 ha hecho cambiar los hábitos de vida
también en la forma en la que nos
relacionamos con las restricciones por
la pandemia en las reuniones entre
amigos o las salidas familiares han
disminuido y muchos se topan de frente
con este mal del siglo 21 la soledad
muchos emprendedores han visto en eso
una vía de negocio y hay empresas como
franca frente a renta un amigo que tiene
más de 600 mil amigos disponibles en
todo el mundo para hacer compañía puede
ser de ayuda pero los médicos advierten
que de persistir estos síntomas de
angustia por soledad
es acudir a un profesional
[Música]
hablar de soledad en colombia es
imposible sin pensar en la universal
novela de gabriel garcía márquez cien
años de soledad quien supo conectar con
ese sentimiento que va de la mano a la
existencia misma del ser humano una
soledad que por motivos demográficos y
culturales aumenta en colombia en los
últimos 15 años han aumentado un 7% las
personas que viven sola por lo que el
país tiene 2,6 millones de personas
viviendo en soledad una opción que en
muchos casos es voluntaria y que no
implican sentirse solos sin embargo la
pandemia sí que ha exacerbado la
cantidad de personas con el sentimiento
profundo de soledad un estudio
colombiano mostró que cuando se
cumplieron seis meses de pandemia el 29
por ciento de la población consultada
presentaba síntomas de ansiedad y el 35
por ciento de depresión un dato que se
dispara en jóvenes con alrededor del 50
por ciento sufriendo ansiedad
ahora con el país prácticamente abierto
estos datos vuelven a quedar en pausa
pero parece temporal con la amenaza de
un segundo confinamiento que puede
volver a disparar la soledad y sus
efectos en la salud mental
[Música]